We are here at the High
Cotton Brewing Company.
And I'm sitting in front of
some very talented comedians.
And I'm excited to talk--
Latoya, Jon Bratsveen, Mo
Alexander, and my man, Cleatis.
Is the comedy scene here in
Memphis, is it a big scene?
Yeah.
From when I first
started here at a club,
the independent
comedy scene came up.
And it's-- you can book--
there's like open mics
almost every night of the week.
So when you say independent,
you mean self-made rooms?
Self-made rooms?
Yeah.
Some of the-- some of the young
comics came up and decided,
they couldn't get
on at the club.
So they started their own stuff.
And now that's-- that's it.
It's booming.
Things are going well.
- Yeah.
As a younger guy here, have
you found a lot of success
by circulating those room?
Oh, yeah.
I mean I'm out there almost
every night of the week
that I can be.
I'm just hitting
every room that I can,
and asking for time anywhere.
Because I feel like, why turn
down any sort of stage time?
I like it.
Do you feel like it's a
diverse group of people?
White comics stay on midtown,
and the black comics
[inaudible].
I think that-- you know,
I go to the white comics.
I think we could
benefit if we would--
we-- we have the same goal.
I remember when
I was starting out,
the one thing that I wanted to
do was perform for everybody,
you know.
And I think maybe
you guys should just
try to take some steps
into diversifying the rules
that you guys have out here.
Because ultimately
we're doing the one
thing that everybody needs.
That's it, providing laughter.
What do you want out of comedy?
What's the ultimate
goal for you?
To take you off your spot.
That's a good goal.
If you want to shoot
for it, shoot for it.
Cleatis, what's that goal, man?
I'm going to be
honest with you, man.
I'm trying to get
high paid around here.
You know what I'm saying?
Because a lot of
you all, though,
always, I'm trying to get rich.
I'm trying to-- you
know, that stage time,
that's my gift to the world.
Like, when I make people
laugh, the feeling I get back
is enough for me.
- Gotcha.
Now all I need is the money.
KEVIN HART: You just need the
money to match that feeling?
Right, right.
You need the money to
catch up to the feeling?
Right, right.
The money and the feeling
need to go together.
Look, I mean this
show is the first step
to more steps to come.
And tonight is about
you making people
understand that there's talent
here in Memphis, Tennessee.